Francis you play you play weevil and
Urich you're you're a gang gang member
your characters a gang member and
sometimes you've struggled a little bit
with being given dialog that didn't feel
to you possibly like it was
authentically from the streets is that
true yes Who am I to judge but I I grew
up all my homeboys are from watts
California North East LA and Rob Thomas
our writer is not from North East LA his
bathroom robots California you know he
got yet some gems in there I think my
vocabulary is definitely increased
what so what's a line that you had to
say over the course the series that just
we you think we thought I no gang member
would save this well for example I think
he always had me picking on little kids
he's always grabbing kids by the couple
they call ends up and once I I had to
grab this this much smaller kid than me
and go somebody's going to Hg double
hockey sticks how many times I tried to
look like Tupac saying that line in the
mirror and it just wasn't working
you know but uh he has a way of just
letting us pull it off you know